there's been another Runway close call
at a major U.S airport this time a jet
blue plane in a charter jet almost
collided at Boston's Logan International
Monday night's incident is the fifth
near crash involving U.S flights this
year Chris Van Cleef has more
a last-second evasive maneuver by
JetBlue Pilots avoided a potentially
disastrous collision at Boston's Logan
Airport Monday night Adam Johnson was on
the flight but we got really close and
then instantly we are rocketing back up
into the air
[Music]
despite that order to wait investigators
say a private Learjet entered the runway
to take off just as JetBlue flight 206
was moments from landing on the same
Runway
the FAA says the private jets pilot
repeated back those instructions but
still proceeded to take off with the
planes coming only about 565 feet from
colliding FlightAware shows the JetBlue
plane roughly 100 feet from the ground
before it abruptly pulls up the incident
comes after a string of close calls
Nelson 1943 cancel takeoff plans all
right and uh oh good job
in January a Delta 737 aborted takeoff
when an American Airlines triple seven
crossed the runway at New York's JFK
self Aesthetics is on the go and last
month the FedEx plane aborted Landing in
Austin Texas after the tower gave it
clearance coming within a hundred feet
from a Southwest flight that was taking
off from the same Runway if the question
is can we better be better the answer is
absolutely and that's the piece we're
working on these recent near collisions
have prompted the faa's acting
administrator to order a safety Summit
taking place later this month
for CBS mornings I'm Chris Van Cleave